the detail is just mind-blowing really  compelling for audiences to go to the  theater and see it and hear it in the  most powerful beautiful cinematic ways  you might wanna buckle up baby  there's a huge adventure sequence  involving the Millennium Falcon I got a  really good feeling about this never  seen the Falcon II flown through so many  challenging corners of the galaxy and  ideal climax experience these movies are  built to take you on an adventure part  of the excitement is creating an  immersive experience that transports you  with the sounds the visuals there's very  little else like that IMAX theatrical  experience it's an immersive movie the  bigger and better the presentation the  richer the experience and it's just not  the same as anything you can get it home  [Music]